[Applaudissements]
entre les vitraux et l'orgue
l'hôtel de l'église protestante
Saint-Guillaume est la scène d'un opéra
de Pergolèse la Servante maîtresse une
version adaptée pour rien inclure les
performances d'anacrobates champion de
Paul dance un blasphème pour certains
qui n'ont pas hésité à écrire et menacés
de mort le pasteur de la paroisse après
un premier spectacle fin mars qu'en
pensez-vous Sarah dans ce cas aller voir
je sais pas faut aller voir ça au Folies
Bergère mais c'est pas le lieu de
l'église quand on va dans j'y vais pas
mais quand on va dans une église c'est
pas pour voir ça donc faut aller au
cabaret au Lido Folies Bergères mais là
c'est complètement indécent enfin je
sais pas on peut faire ça dans une
synagogue pendant qu'on y est enfin je
sais pas en fait non mais moi moi je
peux plus ils sont complètement relayés
dans cette baraque vous êtes des oufs
vous allez me rendre marteau c'est pas
possible le hasard veut que le jour où
j'ai déposé ma plainte en revenant des
responsables de la paroisse avait trouvé
les Flyers là avec des inscriptions à
mort blasphème connard décapitations le
Fat tout arrêter parce que simplement il
y la menace je trouve que c'est donner
vraiment un mauvais signal et 350 000
enfants violets c'est pas contrairement
le lieu a précisément été conçu au
Moyen-Âge pour attirer les pèlerins de
toute l'Europe
[Musique]
on a dans les archives de la ligne dans
les chroniques écrites par les moines la
mention de mort par douzaine 12 pèlerins
étouffés 12 pèlerins écrasés si vous
prenez à la lettre vous dites c'est
horrible mais en fait tout est faux les
moines rajoutent des morts pour attirer
du monde ça fait partie du plan
marketing
on est les seuls à sentir le malaise là
non et lorsque la braguette reste
malencontreusement ouverte un sms une
notification une notification apparaît
sur le téléphone son créateur a posté
une vidéo pour en faire la démonstration
[Musique]
[Rires]
plus Cotentin d'une ferme si je peux la
citer je sais pas la gobillonnerie à
côté de
Saint-Sauveur-le-Vicomte un élevage bio
donc j'ai vu le petit bout avant et
après et vous l'avez devant vous
malheureusement c'est acide mais bon
voilà les plats préférés des Français
numéro 1 le plateau de fruits de mer
mais oui suivi bœuf bourguignon et du
magret de canard le poulet frites et 4e
le couscous complète le top 5 les fruits
les les courses et les légumes les
habits il y a tout qui augmente et du
coup voilà il faut vraiment serrer la
ceinture en fait il y a des capteurs de
mouvement donc la ceinture comprend que
je suis en train de tomber et à ce
moment-là et bah l'airbag se déclenche
instantanément ça prend une demi-seconde
une détresse financières qui rime
souvent avec des tresses psychologiques
54% des Français les plus en difficulté
qu'on fait savoir souffrir d'épisodes
d'anxiété ces 12 derniers mois il y a
juste une petite difficulté il y a deux
difficultés je vais faire le backstage
c'est que vous arrivez vous avez un
véhicule à créditer je vous dépose
devant mais à peu près 200 mètres à
marcher avec une robe longue c'est très
dur ensuite on monte les marches
[Rires]
une fois qu'on parle il y a pas de
véhicule sauf si on regarde tout le film
remplacer par un immigré enfin question
piège avec quel responsable politique
aimeriez-vous partager une bonne bouffe
aucun c'est la première réponse des
Français mais ensuite ces gens la salle
qui arrive en tête au coude à coup avec
François Ruffin donc si on résume le
repas politique idéal des Français c'est
un plateau de fruits de mer avec Jean
Lassalle le premier jour il y avait
Nabilla à côté de moi
deuxième jour j'étais entre Carla Bruni
et Carole Bouquet pas mal pas mal pas
mal pas mal
[Musique]
le fric pas si chic
l'oseille
les gens étaient beaux ils sont tous
beaux
si j'étais un peu riche aussi
[Musique]
on a beaucoup exagéré
non ils très riche il ne le font pas
parce que le but du jeu c'est de
rejoindre une salle de cinéma
non d'accord
avec des belles
hanches bien jolies très faim regardez
j'ai une taille incroyable et ça c'est
parce que tous les jours vraiment
j'essaye de la porter un minimum de 8h
par jour tous des Guignols tous
peut-être pas Nicolas peut-être pas
Jordan le reste que des Guignols mais on
vous a vu la frotter ça va pas toi ils
veulent tu vas le regretter ton choix tu
vas le regretter
et même dans l'air ne prendre l'avion
que quatre fois maximum dans sa vie
c'est la proposition surprenante de
Jean-Marc Jancovici d'ingénieur qui fait
autorité et sur les questions de climat
estime qu'une telle mesure est
nécessaire pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre quand je dis quatre
vols dans une vie c'est pas 0 on
pourrait très bien instaurer un système
dans lequel quand on est jeune on a deux
des quatre vols pour aller découvrir le
monde et puis ensuite quand on est plus
vieux ben on part en vacances en Corrèze
en Corse même on peut aller en bateau
pour voyager loin c'est un peu une
nécessité parce qu'aujourd'hui les
voyages en train pour voyager partout
dans le monde c'est pas forcément
accessible j'aime beaucoup partir en
voyage mais c'est vrai que bah pour des
raisons écologiques ce serait quand même
beaucoup mieux de se raisonner sur ce
point là pour le travail peut-être qu'il
y en a qui ont besoin de faire des
grands trajets à mon avis le trajet en
bateau pour aller aux États-Unis
c'est typiquement le genre de
proposition qui ne correspond pas à
notre société pendant ce temps-là
d'ailleurs on se détourne un peu des
objectifs fondamentaux qui sont de notre
responsabilité à savoir comment baisser
les missions de gaz carbonique mais
c'est pas en Irlande cette façon qu'on y
arrivera manœuvre on a failli en venir
aux mains raconte un député
créneau d'oiseaux ont été échangés le
jeune Vincent des a même traité le
vénérable Charles de Courson de Che
Guevara de la Marne
seul petite seule moment cocasse
peut-être de la journée en français
pourquoi le Sénat est-il à la mode c'est
normal on est les meilleurs
vous avez vu les autres
les autres sous-entendus les députés de
l'Assemblée nationale ils passent leur
temps un peu de Mickey alors ça fait pas
vraiment avancer le chez le Blick
[Applaudissements]